The Hollywood Reporter says Jennifer  Aniston and Reese Witherspoon will star  in a series about TV morning shows the  untitled series explores morning shows  and the larger New York media scene the  project will be shopped to premium cable  networks and streaming services  including Netflix Witherspoon will star  as Gayle King huge boon guest starred as  Aniston's younger sister on the legs on  the show friends and the two have  remained close ever I like the premise  you guys like the premise yeah morning  shows I like it I know who's gonna be  charged there is gonna be a Charlie Rose  character we know that yeah I know who  will it be  I know let's come up with regulate I  don't know if there's anybody that's  there isn't but they can trust Mart  enough cute right yes right  it's Friday yeah